relatives or students who were killed in
luberia secondary school are in mourning
they've come to look for their children
at the morgue girls were hacked to death
with machetes the boys were burned alive
when fighters from the Allied Democratic
forces through a petrol bomb into their
dormitory
some students are missing we just had
very early in the morning yesterday that
the school is banned
and some students have been taken
so I was we have not yet identified
whether is among the the those ones who
were taken or is all is among those who
were banned so we are still waiting for
results
most family members have identified the
students
this family is taking the body of the
adults at home everyone here is in shock
back of the school this is what remains
of the boy's dormitory Witnesses say the
students put up a brave fight and
refused to open the door in the midst of
gunfire Sam Ugandan say this is an
embarrassing security lapse by the
military which is supposed to protect
such borders there are very many
unanswered questions that I need
government to answer today
we have thousands of updf officers in
drsc Congo in the name of securing
Uganda
security forces have increased their
presence in the town the Army is
pursuing the attackers who are saved to
have fled into the virunga national park
enabling Democratic Republic of Congo
the Allied Democratic forces armed group
is based in eastern DRC please do not
panic our children are safe
and they will remain safe
they are evil people
and they are trying to harm our children
but they will not manage
right now these mourners are still
trying to process what happened and why
Catherine soy Al Jazeera Nairobi